GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
TODAY WE HEARD DIRECTLY FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THE INDICTMENT OF RUSSIANS
FOR MEDDLING WITH OUR ELECTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
UNLEASHING ON ITS PREDECESSOR
FOR PREVAILING TO PREVENT THE
SABOTAGE.
SARAH SANDERS ECHOED THAT
EARLIER.
>> EVERYBODY WANTS TO BLAME THIS
ON THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
LET'S NOT FORGET THIS HAPPENED
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
HE'S BEEN TOUGHER ON RUSSIA IN
THE FIRST YEAR THAT OBAMA WAS IN
EIGHT YEARS COMBINED.
>> Jesse: SHE ALSO ADDRESSED
MEDIAS SKEPTICISM ABOUT
MR. TRUMP'S ADMISSION OF
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT MULTIPLE TIMES
BEFORE.
HE ACKNOWLEDGED IT DURING THE
TRANSITION.
HE ACKNOWLEDGED IT DURING A
PRESS CONFERENCE IN POLAND AND
HE ACKNOWLEDGED IT FOR A THIRD
TIME AT A PRESS EVENT IN POLAND.
HE HAS STATED SEVERAL TIMES.
ONE OF THE PLACES WHERE YOU SEEM
TO GET VERY CONFUSED AND IT
SEEMS TO HAPPEN REGULARLY, THE
PRESIDENT HASN'T SAID RUSSIA
DIDN'T METAL.
WHAT HE IS SAYING IS HE DIDN'T
HAVE AN IMPACT AND IT CERTAINLY
WASN'T WITH HELP FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: DANA, YOU BROUGHT UP
THE POINT YESTERDAY THAT
MR. OBAMA DIDN'T WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING PUBLICLY ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN OCTOBER OR
NOVEMBER BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT
TO BE SEEN AS PUBLICLY CREATING
A LOT OF DRAMA FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
COULD HE HAVE NOT DONE SOMETHING
IN THE SHADOWS?
>> Dana: YES, AND IT'S
POSSIBLE THEY DID.
AND THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
COULD BE SOMETHING THEY AREN'T
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
MAYBE THEY COULD DECLASSIFY IT.
THERE'S A RANGE OF THINGS.
I HAD DAN FREED ON THE DAILY
SHOW YESTERDAY.
HE'S A GREAT GUIDE.
WORKED IN MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATIONS.
CAREER CIVIL SERVANT, BECAME AN
AMBASSADOR UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WORKING ON
RUSSIA, UKRAINE ISSUES.
HE SAID IN 2014 THEY WERE HYPER
FOCUSED ON UKRAINE.
AND WHAT TO DO.
THERE IS CONFETTI FLYING DOWN.
>> Jesse: HAPPY NEW YEAR'S.
>> Dana: THEY WERE HYPER
FOCUSED ON THAT ACTIVITY IN 2014
AND THEY DIDN'T REALIZE THE
EXTENT OF THE OPERATION RUSSIA
WAS GOING TO TRY ON THE
ELECTIONS.
THE TECHNOLOGY WAS NEW AND HE
DID SAY THERE COULD HAVE BEEN
MORE THEY COULD HAVE DONE BACK
THEN.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
COULD'VE BEEN SOMETHING THEY
DID.
THERE'S ANOTHER REASON FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO BE MAD AT THE
RUSSIANS.
NOT ONLY DID THEY ATTACK THE
COUNTRY OF WHICH HE IS NOW THE
PRESIDENT.
IF HE HADN'T WON, I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE MAD THIS
HAPPENED ON OUR SOIL.
BUT IT'S ALSO BECAUSE PUTIN'S
ACTIONS HAVE WORKED TO UNDERMINE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
IF I WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP, I
WOULD BE MAD ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS REASON ENOUGH ALONG TO
TRY TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
PUTIN.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
CRITICIZED MR. TRUMP, GREG, FOR
NOT BEING STRONG WHEN IT COMES
TO SANCTIONS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE A LOT
IN TERMS OF THINGS THAT HAS PUT
RUSSIA BACK ON THEIR HEELS, MORE
SO THAN WHAT OBAMA DID.
ON THE SANCTIONS FRONT, PEOPLE
CRITICIZED HIM FOR BEING SOFT.
>> Greg: THERE IS A LOT OF
HYPOCRISY TO GO AROUND.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROTESTS, ANTI-PROTEST BEING
SPONSORED IN THE B BLOCK.
WHAT THE RUSSIANS REPLICATED ON
THE SMALL SCALE IS WHAT WE DO TO
OURSELVES DAILY.
ALL THEY DID WAS THEY SAW OUR
POLITICS.
I AM MORE WORRIED ABOUT BIGGER
THREATS.
I AM WORRIED ABOUT OUR BANKING
AND POWER GRID.
THAT IS THE STUFF.
THAT'S THE STUFF WE SURVIVE ON.
WE CAN LIVE WITH TROLLS, EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE A PAIN IN THE
NECK.
WE CAN LIVE WITH TROLLS.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM HERE IS
POLITICAL PARTY LEADERS DON'T
CARE ABOUT THREATS UNLESS THEY
ARE A THREAT TO THEIR POWER.
RIGHT?
IT'S NOT SO MUCH A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES BUT HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT OUR ELECTION.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT BUGS ME MOST
ABOUT DEMOCRATS.
THEY REALLY AREN'T THAT TICKED
OFF ABOUT THE RUSSIANS UNTIL
EMOTIONALLY THEY WERE AFFECTED
BY THE LOSS OF HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT'S WHAT'S DRIVING THEIR
ANGER AND THAT TRUMP WON.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE MAD AT THE
RUSSIANS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT THE
COUNTRY AS MUCH AS THAT THEY
LOST.
>> Jesse: TO YOUR POINT, WOULD
YOU HAVE HAD PRESIDENT OBAMA
SLAPPED SANCTIONS ON THE
RUSSIANS IF HILLARY HAD WON?
HE MAY NOT HAVE DONE IT.
HE MAY HAVE SAID IT'S NOT AN
ISSUE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE
ANYTHING OUT OF IT.
>> Dana: REALLY?
YOU THINK THEY WOULD HAVE LET IT
GO?
>> Jesse: IF HILLARY HAD WON
AND THERE WASN'T THIS CRAZY
RUSSIA-TRUMP ELECTION COLLUSION.
>> Dana: I THOUGHT YOU MEANT
IF THE RUSSIANS WERE TRYING TO
COLLUDE WITH THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: I AM SAYING IF
HILLARY HAD WON MY DON'T THINK
OBAMA WOULD'VE SLAPPED SANCTIONS
ON THE RUSSIANS.
>> Kimberly: IT'S A CONCERTED
EFFORT BY THE DEMOCRATS TO
DELEGITIMIZE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ELECTION VICTORY.
THERE ISN'T SPECIFIC EMPIRICAL
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST IN SUGGEST
IN FACT IT HAD AN IMPACT ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
WE CERTAINLY KNOW THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THERE WAS
TAMPERING WITH THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
THE SUGGESTION IS THESE BOTS
WERE OPERATING AND THAT THEY
WERE DOING THIS WHOLE THING TO
TRY TO CREATE CHAOS WITHIN THE
AMERICAN POLITICAL SYSTEM,
WITHIN THE ELECTION CYCLE AND
DISRUPTING IN THAT WAY.
BUT THERE ISN'T ANY EVIDENCE TO
SAY IT ACTUALLY AFFECTED THE
OUTCOME.
IT WAS OUT THERE, AND SOME OF IT
WAS OUT THERE BUT IT WASN'T IN
SUCH A WAY LARGE-SCALE FORCE
THAT I THINK IT WOULD HAVE AN
ULTIMATE EFFECT.
NOW EVERYONE IS WHINING ABOUT
IT.
GUESS WHAT.
RUSSIANS WERE NO RUSSIANS,
HILLARY LOST.
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF WHINING,
PRESIDENT OBAMA I THINK IN
OCTOBER SAID THIS TO MR. TRUMP
WHO WAS COMPLAINING ABOUT READY
TO ELECTIONS.
>> THERE IS NO SERIOUS PERSON
OUT THERE WHO WOULD SUGGEST
SOMEHOW THAT YOU COULD EVEN RIG
AMERICA'S ELECTIONS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE PAST OR THAT
THERE ARE INSTANCES IN WHICH
THAT WILL HAPPEN THIS TIME.
AND SO I WOULD ADVISE MR. TRUMP
TO STOP WHINING AND GO TRY TO
MAKE HIS CASE TO GET VOTES.
>> Jesse: JUAN.
>> Juan: THIS IS, TO ME.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS RESPONDING
TO THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP SAYING
HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT VOTER
FRAUD, THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LINE UP OR THAT THE BIG
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MACHINES AND
CITIES WERE GOING TO SOMEHOW RIG
THE ELECTION AGAINST HIM.
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
RESPONDING TO.
NOW TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP COMING
BACK, USE THAT QUOTE YOU JUST
SAW ON THE SCREEN AND SAYS THAT
WAS ABOUT RUSSIAN MEDDLING.
>> Jesse: CAN I RESPOND?
BECAUSE WHEN TRUMP WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE ELECTION BEING RIGGED,
I THINK HE WAS TALKING ABOUT NOT
ONLY THE POTENTIAL FOR -- HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT STATE POLLS, COMEY
LETTING HILLARY OFF THE HOOK,
THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
>> Jesse: HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
VOTER FRAUD, POINTING TO
MINORITIES IN SAYING THIS IS HOW
THEY ARE GOING TO DO IT IN THE
BIG CITIES.
EVEN SUGGESTING HE WOULDN'T
HONOR THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION BECAUSE HE WAS SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS KIND OF
ACTIVITY.
HAD NOTHING TO DO AT THAT POINT
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
HERE WE ARE TODAY, AND WE ARE
HAVING A DISCUSSION THAT SAYS
OH, NO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN'T DISTORTING
THE NEWS AND ISN'T MISQUOTING
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
WE TREATED LIKE IT'S SERIOUS.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION.
EVEN OVER THE WEEKEND, YOU STOP
AND THINK HE IS ATTACKING
McMASTER, HIS OWN NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR FOR SAYING THE
RUSSIANS DEFINITELY INTERFERED
IN THE ELECTION.
YOU COME FORWARD AND SAY WHY
ISN'T HE IS IMPOSING SANCTIONS?
HE IS DOING MORE THAN OBAMA?
OBAMA THROUGHOUT 35 DIPLOMATS,
HE CLOSED DOWN TWO RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATIC ESTATES IN THE
UNITED STATES AND IMPOSE
SANCTIONS AND YET WE ARE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS THAT HE DID MORE
THAN OBAMA?
HE IS NOT DOING ANYTHING?
>> Jesse: HE DID THAT AFTER
THE ELECTION AND THEN ENDED UP
DROPPING THE SANCTIONS BUSH PUT
IN PLACE AND ALLOWING RUSSIA TO
SELL ANTIAIRCRAFT TO IRAN.
THE DEMOCRATS WHEN THEY WERE
RUNNING WILD ON PRESIDENT OBAMA,
THEY DIDN'T CARE TOO MUCH.
THE MINUTE THEY DENIGRATE
HILLARY, THAT'S WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS REALLY BECOME COLD
WARRIORS.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT IS
GREG'S POINT.
THAT'S WHY IT'S HARD TO TAKE.
WE KNOW IF IT'D BEEN THE OTHER
WAY AROUND, AND AS I WAS SAYING,
I MISUNDERSTOOD WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING EARLY.
IF HILLARY HAD WON AND THE
REPUBLICANS AND REASON TO
BELIEVE THE RUSSIANS WERE TRYING
TO HELP HILLARY WIN AND MAKE
TRUMP LOSE, WHAT WOULD WE BE
SAYING EVERY DAY?
I THINK THEY ARE DOING WHAT THEY
ARE GOING TO DO.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY HAVE
SPENT SO MUCH TIME ON RUSSIA
THAT NOW THE DEMOCRATS, YOU CAN
SEE IT IN THE POLLING, THEY ARE
STARTING TO REALIZE THAT
ACTUALLY MIGHT BE ON THEIR HEELS
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS BECAUSE THE TAX REFORM
PIECE HAS MOVED FORWARD AND
THERE WAS A QUOTE FROM JONATHAN
SWAN ON AXIOS ON THE DEMOCRATIC
POLLSTER SAYING REPUBLICANS HAVE
THE WRONG MESSAGE BUT DEMOCRATS
HAVE NO MESSAGE.
THAT THAT ACTUALLY, WHILE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA, THE
PRESIDENT HAS MOVED FORWARD AND
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE HELPED HIM
MOVE FORWARD ON POLICY AND
DEMOCRATS HAVE SEEDED THAT
GROUND, HOPING THIS WOULD BE
THEIR SAVING GRACE.
>> Greg: I KIND OF SAID THE
SAME THING SWAN SAID BUT SO MUCH
BETTER YESTERDAY.
>> Kimberly: AND HE HAS A NICE
ACCENT.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU ARE AN
OLYMPIC ATHLETE AND ALL YOU
TRAIN FOR IS CURLING AND YOU
HAVE NO BACKUP JOBS OR WHEN THE
CURLING IS OVER AND THE
OLYMPIC'S ARE GONE AND YOU
DIDN'T WIN, YOU CAN'T -- CURLING
HAS NO TRANSFERABLE SKILLS.
>> Kimberly: YOU ARE STILL
TRYING TO MAKE THAT WORK.
>> Greg: THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
STORY IS THERE CURLING THEY'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT THEIR BACKUP
PLAN.
THEY WILL PROBABLY GET ONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WILL BE, THAT
TRUMP IS AWFUL.
I THINK YOU HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE
SO VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO HIM.
WORKED WITH THE REPUBLICANS AND
OBAMA.
ALL YOU HAD TO SAY IS I DON'T
LIKE OBAMA AND THAT WILL WORK.
I THINK THAT WILL PROBABLY WORK
FOR THE DEMOCRATS WITH TRUMP,
BUT THEY STILL DON'T HAVE A
PLAN.
THEY ARE STILL CURLING.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT'S
IT.
I DO AGREE THEY DON'T HAVE A
CLEAR SIGNAL MESSAGE OTHER THAN
ANTI-TRUMP, BUT I DO THINK WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING IS PEOPLE -- DANA
WAS TALKING A MOMENT AGO ABOUT
THE TAX PLAN BECOMING MORE
POPULAR.
I THINK IT'S NOW OVER 50%.
BUT LET ME SAY IF YOU WERE TO
HAVE A POLL ON ICE CREAM AND
APPLE PIE, WOULDN'T YOU EXPECT,
LIKE A TAX CUT FOR EVERYBODY,
THAT YOUR NUMBERS WOULD BE IN
THE 80s OR 90s.
>> Greg: NOT ME.
MY STOMACH CANNOT HANDLE
ICE CREAM.
>> Juan: PEOPLE REALIZE HOW
MUCH OF THIS MONEY IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO THE RICH AND
CORPORATIONS AND THEY DON'T LIKE
IT.
I WOULD SAY THIS ABOUT THE
RUSSIA STUFF.
WHY ISN'T THIS PRESIDENT WON'T
IMPOSE THE SANCTIONS?
WHY WON'T HE TAKE PROACTIVE
ACTION IN TERMS OF STOPPING THE
ONGOING INTERFERENCE IN OUR
POLITICS BY THE RUSSIANS?
>> Kimberly: WHY DIDN'T
PRESIDENT OBAMA DO IT.
>> Juan: THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
I WANT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION,
KIMBERLY.
BECAUSE KIMBERLY WOULD HAVE SAT
HERE AND SAID LOOK AT OBAMA.
HE IS SAYING THE RUSSIANS ARE
INTERFERING TO BENEFIT TRUMP.
HE IS ACTUALLY HELPING HILLARY I
DOING IT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CONSERVATIVES
WOULD HAVE SAID.
>> Kimberly: EARNED THEIR
VOTES.
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
DON'T WHY AND CRY ABOUT IT IF
YOU ARE NOT A GOOD CANDIDATE.
>> Greg: A LOT OF THE STUFF
PEOPLE ARE GETTING ALL TICKED
OFF ABOUT OUR TRUMP'S TWEETING.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE IN THE
PRESS HAVE EVER HAD A BOSS.
BOSSES DO THIS.
THEY SNAPPED, THEY YELL.
5 MINUTES LATER THEY FORGET.
IT'S LIKE MOVING TO SEATTLE AND
WAKING UP EVERY MORNING AND
BEING SHOCKED IT IS RAINING.
THAT IS THE MEDIA AFTER A YEAR
AND HALF OF TRUMP.
EVERY MORNING THEY WAKE UP AND
THEY ARE SHOCKED, SHOCKED.
THE BEST BOSSES IN THE WORLD,